o que você está Qual é a sua missão o
que você quer alcançar é por o como
nunca pode ser a
missão na minha opinião de novo sempre o
como não pode ser a minha uma missão a
missão é o que você eh quer entregar o
que você quer proporcionar o mundo aos
seus clientes a indústria pra empresa eh
ou como e te ajuda né e e te permite
deveria te habilitar
a entregar é criar o qu mas nunca é o
fim e muitas vezes eu vejo muitas
organizações seja de tecnologia seja de
produto seja de design
eh esquecer que metodologia processos eh
e todas as coisas que a gente que a pm3
ensina para as pessoas são comos não são
qu é que o sucesso não vem de quanto bem
você faz o desenvolvimento do produto O
sucesso vem do produto do do quanto o
produto é adotado pelos seus clientes
Qual é a experiência o feedback dos seus
clientes se resolvem a dor do cliente ou
[Música]
[Aplausos]
não Olá cara ouvinte seja bem-vindo a
mais de produto eu sou Marcel Almeida c
da pm3 e hoje a gente vai dar
continuação aquela série de entrevistas
com líderes do mercado de tecnologia que
a Fernanda faria me desafiou pra gente
começar a entrevistar líderes e
aprofundar em vários assuntos e
obviamente Ela tá aqui hoje novamente
como corros bem-vinda Fê continuando a
nossa jornada no nosso novo ciclo
Olímpico isso aí isso aí e só quem
assistiu o primeiro episódio dessa série
vai saber essa
piadinha e nosso convidado especial
desse Episódio é o Roberto mameli Ele é
diretor de Tecnologia da simpla já
passou por empresas como creditas de
impz tem mais de 15 anos de experiência
na área Roberto é um prazer ter você
aqui é um prazer estar aqui é ser
convidado para Fernanda principalmente
aqui pm3 é vocês trabalharam juntos né
Não acredito pô foi os melhores líderes
que eu já trabalhei por isso que a gente
ol olha olha só então a gente vai ter
vai ter muitos aprendizados aqui hoje
muitos Roberto pra gente começar essa
conversa eu queria saber sobre a sua
bagagem de mais de 15 anos com conta o
que que você como que você evoluiu
nesses 15 anos inclusive provavelmente
crenças que você quebrou Aposto que o
Roberto de 10 anos atrás tinha crenças
que hoje talvez sejam outras é legal a
gente saber esse seu aprendizado como
líder e como amadurecimento na carreira
como foi esse processo Claro bom como
vocês vão
perceber que sou Ringo não sou não sou
brasileiro nasci foi criado na
itlia assim que me formei em Ciência da
Computação tive uma oportunidade de ir
para os Estados Unidos achava que fosse
um estágio de humano e se tornou um
estágio de uma vida até 7 anos atrás eh
quando eu mudei para o Brasil e mas eh
do ponto de vista profissional sempre e
a minha o meu desenvolvimento
profissional nos Estados Unidos
principalmente maioria na Vale do
Silício e comecei como desenvolvedor
Então sou uma pessoa técnica e eu
continuei evoluindo em outras áreas
interessante que talvez uma das dos
pontos mais transformadores da minha
carreira foi muitos anos atrás quando eu
comecei a trabalhar para uma empresa que
se chama macr chamava macromia que adob
comprou né que a comprou foi na verdade
fui antes da da aquisição da da Adobe E
por que foi um momento marcante porque
macromia é uma empresa
onde tanto tecnologia Quanto prodot era
complementada ença super importante da
importância da
experiência Então na verdade já lá nessa
a palavra experiência a importância da
experiência
ah na dentro do do de tecnologia muitas
vezes pessoas que né a gente gosta de
falar de apis gosta de falar de
frameworks gosta de falar de linguagens
e tudo isso eh e numa empresa onde a
experiência era a coisa mais importante
a experiência era o produto que macromia
estava eh
vendia fazia parte da cultura do DNA da
empresa e quando você entra em empresa
assim você começa a absorber Exatamente
Essa primeira essa primeira criança a
importância de de da experiência além do
produto além da tecnologia e foi assim
que para mim nunca foi mais sobre só
tecnologia ou só sobre
eh a parte técnica eh e claramente com
isso depois eu passei para para outra
Startup passei Tod Startup tanto Startup
quanto empresas mais eh maiores e
evoluindo e passando para umas
revoluções do mercado a jaal uma das
Prime uma das Prim mundo digital eu
lidei liderei a a transformação digital
lá nos Estados Unidos como último
trabalho que fiz antes de mudar para cá
a transformação digital da maior empresa
de seguros tradicionais eh nos Estados
Unidos que chamava All state Ah se chama
All state a maior dos Estados Unidos
onde a gente eu liderei a transformação
digital de uma empresa desse tamanho
e e e aí Talvez um outro momento
marcante de como de de como por exemplo
eh uma das crenças dessa do ainda lembro
do se falava eu quero ser uma empresa
pelo bem a gente a gente vende seguros a
gente claramente a gente mas a gente
quer ser uma empresa pelo bem então aí
comprometimento social comprometimento a
deixar as coisas melhores como você está
Ach eh está achando que não é só um
princípio tanto social humano mas é um
princípio que você pode eh que eu adotei
e e assimilei dentro do que a gente faz
dentro de uma empresa até dentro de
tecnologia Tanto que uma das dos dos a
gente tem um Manifesto dentro da simpla
eh um dos valores desse Manifesto é
deixamos as coisas melhores do que
achamos como isso pode ser no código por
exemplo eu isso AC tenho um produto
estou evoluindo o produto preciso deixar
o produto melhor do que eu achei pode
ser a nível social também então são
algumas dessas dessas eh cências Então
acho que esses são os pontos principais
né e conceito de experiência
ah conceito de que significa ser digital
ah e o que é a transformação digital a
gente passou né a gente está na próxima
transformação agora e é como lidar com
transformações porque no no final das
contas
eh o que sabe é a expressão que te troue
até aqui não te leva para lá isso é
super importante muitas vezes as pessoas
querem continuar fazendo as coisas do
mesmo jeito eh inclusive para fazer
produto do mesmo jeito uhum ah é parte
da da agilidade na verdade é parte do
que
eh faz tanto uma empresa quanto um
sucesso é aib é a abertura e o entender
que tudo em movimento tudoo em movimento
então ser aberto ao movimento ser aberto
a mudança Isso é muito difícil é uma das
coisas mais difícil para até para o ser
humano né se adaptar às mudanças e tudo
e tudo o resto Então essa foi uma essa
foi o caminho até mudei para o Brasil e
aí foi uma oportunidade maravilhosa de
novo estô aqui há 7 anos trabalhando
para empresas maravilhosas como gimpa
creditas agora simpla
eh tive a sorte de
de ter a Fernanda como product produto
lá na na acreditas E aí foi também nessa
parte da e o
impacto cultural diferência cultural e
outra outro conceito que eu vejo muito
que a gente gosta muito de falar de
diversidade né mas muitas vezes eu sinto
que a gente esquece de uma parte
importante de diversidade que é a
diversidade cultural diversidade
personalidade das pessoas
eh diversidade não é só Raça sexo e tudo
isso e gender desculpa como sei como se
fala mas é a diversidade é também a
diversidade cultural e e a importância
da diversidade das pessoas para dentro
de um time dentro de uma empresa que não
é só porque a todo mundo agora quer ver
porque tem valor eu que acredito demais
fazendo parte da da sendo desenvolvendo
na na na Califórnia né na Vale do
Silício é que ou um dos valores mais e
das das das chaves principais do Sucesso
da Vale de silício é a diversidade
cultural e a diversidade das pessoas
ninguém nasceu na Vale de silício
ninguém nasceu na
Califórnia maioria das pessoas são
pessoas que vêm de todos os lugares do
mundo com ideias diferentes culturas
diferentes tudo essa diversidade é o que
faz na minha opinião a a a fortaleza da
da da Vale do Silício e e para mim é
isso que é algo por isso que é tão
importante dentro de times diversidade
seja o time de produto seja o time de
tecnologia se time de uma em as
organizações de uma empresa a
diversidade isso que faz a empresa mais
forte Então essas são um pouco da o
resumo da das minhas dos meus
aprendizados e e tanto de de vida quanto
profissionais e e hoje na Simples você
tá como diretor de tecnologia e e eu
queria entender como que funciona a
estrutura de vocês lá a tecnologia é só
a parte de desenvolvimento software ou
também tem produto também tem ux como é
que vocês estão organizados lá hoje
certo ah eu sou responsável como C
responsável na daárea intera que dentro
da simpla a gente chama de produto
estava falando com a Fernanda aqui pouco
que a gente é uma organização de
Tecnologia é uma organização de produto
e
tecnologia produto e tecnologia produto
é super interess interessante porque
todo mundo pensa ah tecnologia então CTO
sou tecnologia Ah eu acredito demais que
na verdade você vê que tem também alguns
perfis de
CTO hoje em dia são CTO que na verdade
entendem produto são CTO de produto PR
da technology e que não tem mais essa
diferencia entre CPO e CTO ah claramente
Ainda existe essa essa essa essa
diferença mas se você olh algumas
empresas
airbnb o CTO o CPO CTO é é um perfil eh
eh na mesma pessoa eu não consigo me ver
só como CTO tanto que não consigo me ver
só como como CPO até porque
eh a gente pode conversar O que
significa ser uma empresa de tecnologia
né mas todo mundo fala ah Queremos ser
uma empresa de tecnologia o que
significa isso mas no final no final das
contas se você não faz a e é rend rend
você tá entregando um produto você tá
entregando valor e via um produto E como
falei para mim até além de produto é uma
experiência né quando você consegue
entregar além de um produto uma
experiência e de qualquer forma sem você
querer quando você entrega um produto
você entrega uma experiência é que você
não sabe qual experiência você está
entregando porque você está pensando ao
produto ao produto produto em si então é
melhor saber que você está entregando na
experiência assim que você tem controle
Via o produto que você está
desenvolvendo da experiência que você
quer gerar e quer Eh proporcionar para
os seus clientes então
ah voltando a sua pergunta eu sou C mas
responsável para todas as áreas que tem
que inclui produto eh design e aí a
gente pode também conversar se lembra
Fernanda eh da importância que se Você
acredita que a experiência é tão
importante estratégica o time de design
né é um time que tem que ser que ter o
mesmo protagonismo na mesa e não
subordinado ao produto mas o mesmo
protagonismo na mesa do produto como
quando falo produto prod Management
nesse caso tecnologia como que tem
engenheria H eh prod Engineering eh
devops em geral evolução as evoluções né
de de G Dev vobs ah platform Engineering
Cyber
eh service and support toda praticamente
infraestrutura Cloud operations todas
essas áreas e que fazem parte Ness PR
simpla tanto na simpla quanto no gypass
quant não acreditas er a mesma o mesmo
tipo de eh responsabilidade e
organização legal isso que você falou eu
tenho visto como uma certa tendência no
mercado mesmo de CTO e CPO cada vez mais
junto já vi gente até colocando CPO né
No No NO ledin de fato faz sentido
porque cada vez mais a gente percebe que
produto não é só feito pela área de
produto produto é de todo mundo produto
é da área até o marketing impacta no
produto o jeito que ele comunica vai
impactar em como as pessoas percebem
aquele produto Às vezes o texto do da
funcionalidade do que tá escrito ali no
produto impacta Então essa visão é muito
legal eh ver cada vez ela mais difundida
principalmente no Brasil que ainda é
ainda é algo novo o produto querendo ou
não e nessa visão assim como líder né e
montando times o que que foi
eh mais difícil de conseguir trazer essa
visão para todo mundo de est tudo junto
de no final das contas todo mundo Olha o
produto e o que que foi mais fácil assim
onde você acha que é o clique das
pessoas assim como você teve o Clique na
experiência essa é uma pergunta bem
difícil porque
eh cada pessoa é diferente e o que clica
uma pessoa não clica outra esse é o
nosso desafio a gente muitas vezes usa
ou tenta usar seja a metodologia seja o
modelo seja a abordagem que a gente
acredita que funcione para todos e todas
né isso infelizmente infelizmente não é
o caso então
hã tanto como é interessante o desafio
principal o maior desafio para mim é
exatamente como é que faz liderança
individual e não uma liderança geral
e mas no mesmo
tempo o que acho que ainda comum
eh que a gente tentou fazer juntos né
Fernanda não acreditas
é comunicar e alinhar sobre a visão
missão né missão e visão muitas vezes a
gente fala ah missão visão estratégia de
novo usando como metodologia porque tá
escrito no mercado que você tem que
fazer isso mas na verdade e todos nós
somos motivados por razões diferentes
mas pelo menos compartil é importante é
necessário compartilhar Onde você está
indo eu por você está indo É acho que é
onde é o porqu
eh a clareza disso a inspiração que vem
de saber onde é por eu acho que é o
ponto comum acredito que é o ponto comum
o resto é individual como falei Todos
nós temos personalidades diferentes
motivações
ah motivações diferentes
de resiliências diferente atitude
diferente é interessante uma das coisas
que estamos olhando que estamos vendo né
conceito de eh especialmente dentro de
time conceito de ansiedade de Burnout
mas o que gera ansiedade gera Burnout é
diferente para cada pessoa então e essa
liderança tanto liderança quanto gestão
Ah tem que descer o nível ao nível
individual Esse é o desafio se você
aplica um padrão geral
claramente você atinge só um um um um
número reduzido de pessoas é o desafio é
quanto mais você consegue
H tocar cada pessoa com eh o que motiva
elas ess eu não tenho ainda a resposta
tô continuando tô continuando a tentar
ver qual é a mas e e a importância é
conhecer é conhecer a pessoa é saber o
que o que motiva a pessoa P eh um pouco
do histórico das pessoas que todos nós
temos um histórico que impata
h para conseguir fazer esse Impacto
individual Você acha que tem um um
limite máximo de quantas pessoas um
líder consegue liderar diretamente tipo
ah por exemplo se ele lidera diretamente
30 pessoas é muito diferente do que se
ele liderar cinco qual qual você acha
que é esse número talvez número mágico
colocar entre aspas cara é engraçado
porque essa
pergunta eh não
eh a a resposta para o que eu aprendi
que a resposta paraa maioria das
perguntas talvez 99% da pergunta é
depende e Esso é um exemplo Ah eu não
fico eu eu não gosto muito de
eh de regras né Eh claramente tem
indicações tem eh por exemplo a formação
um PM para cada sete sete
desenvolvedores ou e você não consegue
gerenciar mais de X pessoas tem uma
verdade ao redor disso mas ah h quando
essa verdade quando essa essa verdade
esse número se torna uma regra eu acho
que aí a gente perde ah o a importância
e e e perde a flexibilidade de o de
saber o que você está querendo alcançar
e e e como eu o como você tem que
ajustar então eu sou um pouco eu eh ao
longo dos anos participando de de de
transformação digital transformando
participando de ajal participando de
também todas as evoluções de de
tecnologia eu comecei a ficar um pouco
alérgico a a as regras e as metodologias
Quando essas metodologias não são
inspirações ou indicações mas se tornam
ah processo por exemplo se tornam o
quase o fim ao invz do como e essa é uma
das coisas que até falava muito
eh seja processo seja regras seja
eh são sempre deve ser sempre ao serviço
do que você está querendo entregar
e e por isso que às vezes eu fiz sempre
acho importante fazer ess fazer essa
pergunta faço muitas vezes pergunta para
meu time o que o que a gente está
conversando aqui está respondendo aqui
responde a pergunta o que ou
como e por essa pergunta para mim é
super
importante porque se a gente gasta muito
tempo sobre como esqueça que eu como
esqueça o quê Ah a gente está falhando
Na minha opinião
hah e muitas vezes eu vejo muitas
organizações gastando um monte de tempo
sobre o quê o que se tornar o fim e
considerar o
sucesso que o fato que o como se tornou
o melhor como da indústria quando na
verdade o que importa é o que voltando a
o que você está Qual é a sua missão o
que você quer alcançar é por o como
nunca pode ser a
missão na minha opinião de novo sempre o
como não pode ser a minha uma missão a
missão é o que você eh quer entregar o
que você quer proporcionar o mundo aos
seus clientes a indústria a pra empresa
eh ou como eh te ajuda né e e te permite
deveria te habilitar a entregar e a
criar o qu mas nunca é o fim e muitas
vezes eu vejo muitas organizações seja
de tecnologia seja de produto seja de
design
eh esquecer que metodologia processos eh
e todas as coisas que a gente que aet
ensina pessoas não que e que o sucesso
não vem quanto bem você faz o
desenvolvimento do produto sucesso vem
do
produto do quanto o produto é adotado
pelos seus clientes Qual é a experiência
o feedback dos seus clientes se resolve
dor do cliente ou não e isso é super
importante às vezes sinto que falta ISO
tanto em esola de produto quanto em
esola de tecnologia quanto
que no final das contas a missão é do
que você está querendo é um que e o que
se materializa via o produto é a
experiência é no final que experiência
Você quer entregar e o Framework que
você vai usar o processo que você vai
usar ele vai ser adaptativo né mas eu
também a discussão Até que a gente teve
no outro Episódio foi muito sobre o fato
de que você ter processos e métodos ele
ele facilita o como e às vezes Nem
facilita às vezes atrapalha você escolhe
o processo errado pro pro como atalha
eh mas uma das coisas que a gente tava
discutindo era muito sobre
repertório que na verdade fica mais
fácil quando você tem mais repertório
escolher o como uhum e aí a gente viu a
gente tava discutindo até de muito das
pessoas que durante a pandemia né eram
Juniors e viraram Sênior muito rápido e
essa falta de repertório o que que que
você sente hoje em relação a isso ah eu
eh você usou a palavra que sempre estava
procurando é o repertório ch uma caixa
de ferramentas parece que às vezes se
você tem um encantador chegando em casa
só com só com uma ferramenta às vezes eu
sinto que a
gente trabalha nessas condições
agil scum e tudo é a única coisa o
produto metodologia de produto a
importância na verdade é o repertório é
não poderia concordar mais do que você
acabou de Fal falando agora que é
eh ajuda e deveria ajudar e facilitar e
quanto mais repertórios quanto mais
ferramentas você tem
H melhor você consegue alcançar o o qu
né cons entregar e alcançar o que e
eh Há tempo atrás tinha H tem um um e um
filme que se chama Alem da vida um filme
muito antigo não sei se vocês lembram
EAV fando qu é dien ent concio e
sabedoria concio é você ler um livro e
aprender conhecimento é você fazer um
curso pm3 e aprender e você sai com e
você sai com um conhecimento Mas isso
não é sabedoria a sabedoria vend da
praticar o conhecimento ter praticado
conhecimento em situações diferentes aí
vem o repertório e e isso infelizmente
não significa que ah que você mede isso
baseado no número de anos de experiência
que você tem na profissão não não é
necessário mas repertório você construi
ao longo do tempo então quando você
corre também até na carreira Quando você
corre em
em o tempo limitado ainda Precisa de
tempo porque o
repertório se se é o repertório de
Sabedoria só acontece quando você
praticou e se você é para praticar
precisa de tempo Você não pratica você
aprende você pode aprender em humano
pode aprender no curso na evolução de um
curso mas a sabedoria de fazer isso é
construir o repertório que que a
Fernanda estava falando aí demora tempo
agora não tem regra você quanto tempo
não isso de novo é igual a pergunta que
você me fez quantas pessoas Qual é o
máximo de pessoas que você pode liderar
Qual é isso isso não é o ponto o ponto é
que que claramente para fazer uma
liderança e uma gestão individual você
não pode ter um um número alto de
pessoas para fazer para construir o
repertório não você você precisa de
experiência de mercado e precisa pessoas
de estar ao redor de pessoas que tiveram
essa experiência é muita porque muita
dessa experiência é translativa no
sentido que passa de pessoa para pessoa
passa do seu Líder para o liderado e um
dos maiores Eu acho que um das das
maiores orgulhos e gratificações para um
para um líder e ver eh os seus liderados
até te ultrapassar na na tanto na
carreira quanto no eh no sucesso e você
tava falando um pouco diante de
transformação
digital que é um pouco mais complexo é
de
fazer quando você olha compara a simpla
onde você tá hoje os desafios são muito
diferentes da transformação digital mas
o que que tem em comum nesses dois
mundos e só para dar contexto Quantas
pessoas tem na simpla hoje na simpla
inteira como empresa acho
290 290 pessoas é o time de de produto
que inclui todas essas áreas que eu 92
tá 92 pessoas e que é relativamente
pequena né porque empresa transformação
digital geralmente são empresas com
muito mais não exatamente na última
empresa que falei são a gente estava
falando até não só da essas empresas são
empresas internacionais uma empresa
também que tem
eh mais do que uma do que uma empresa
dentro da empresa Business units todas
essas eh essas hierarquias então
Hã Eu acho que
eh desculpa eh similaridade similaridade
da transformação digital a transformação
digital criar um produto num ambiente
menor quando eu penso eh em
transformação digital eu penso na
eh qual é o valor da digitalização no
final das contas Ach o valor último da
digitalização é empoderar o indivíduo a
fazer coisas que antes não era poss que
antes eram
intermediadas o que acontece é
que isso não significa deo outro estremo
da isso não significa que eh até que
agora eu estou mudando falando de usar
digital porque eh agora as pessoas Às
vezes tem esse objetivo que não tem mais
ser humano Inclusive inclusive agora com
inteligência artificial né que tem
claramente o potencial de de
desintermediação
digital mas h eu acredito muito que esse
empoderamento
do indivíduo a fazer as coisas a se
servir via tecnologia via produto e
tudo ainda sempre precisa eu acredito
até com inteligência artificial eu
acredito demais que ainda vai precisar
de da possibilidade ou da existência de
um contato humano por isso
que eu gusto eu prefiro agora essa
palavra de figital né que todo mundo
está falando de figital eu acho para mim
super importante mas claramente quando a
gente estava em um mundo totalmente
intermediado por humanos e totalmente
intermediado por pessoas transformação
digital era o sonho né o sonho era cara
não preciso mais
e no mundo de seguros não preciso mais
de corretores no mundo de de de de
comida só posso pedir a comida chegar
diretamente no meu na minha porta esse
tipo de coisas
mas essa é a primeira parte Mas qual foi
para mim a coisa super importante da
transformação digital é que quando você
começa a desintermediação
[Música]
é você tem que pensar primeiro quem que
vai usar o seu produto quem quem o que a
pessoa quer fazer e qual é a experiência
que você quer que essa pessoa tenha com
com esse com esse produto Então acho que
os pontos comuns no final das contas é
customer first pensar primeiro não é o
negócio não é pensar primeiro a e a
pessoa ao cliente ao cliente final
então aí eu entro nessa conversa que de
novo não é customer centric customer
first e eu uso muito aqui eu preciso
reconhecer a Amazon como de novo
transformadora de de dessa Cultura né
dentro de de desenvolvimento que a gente
que é o working backwards Ah é
interessante que ainda as empresas times
ainda
eh tem dificuldade a pensar backwards
pensar
se você é customer first E você começa
com o cliente seja o
cliente o indivíduo seja o cliente uma
organização no caso que você desenvolve
um enterprise software se um produto
enterprise seja qualquer seja se você
começa do
cliente
aí verdade o único jeito de trabalhar é
backwards e e é isso essa é ainda muito
muito muito difícil ainda muito pouco
praticado desenvolvimento de produto com
com working backwards Começando por
exemplo Amazon F da press release
começando da do valor que você quer
entregar e depois de lá você começa a
construir o case até chegar a qual é
arquitetura que vai precisar para fazer
isso é muito é muito pouco praticado mas
eu para mim é uma crença que ainda é um
ah algo super importante para mim é é o
é a resposta ao que precisa é o sucesso
na minha opinião Por que que você acha
que a gente ainda tem bastante
dificuldade de praticar em geral porque
claramente tem necessidade de negócio né
No final das contas tem um negócio que
tem que ser rentável como é que a gente
ainda não consegue necessariamente
eh criar métrica de sucesso de negócio
baseado no cliente sempre baseado na
receita baseado emessa é muito
importante pelo menos MPS É acho que MPS
é a única métrica que hoje todas as
empresas eh acompanham pensando a eh
como sucesso né claramente uma empresa
que tem pode ter um sucesso eh
financeiro muito com um NPS muito baixo
todo mundo acredita que H que seja que
não seja algo que vai eh é sustentável
sustentá mas
eh fora do MPS que acho que pelo menos
que é super importante todas as nossas
outras métricas de métricas financeiras
métricas econômicas e tudo são baseadas
em negócio são baseada baseada
e o fato que
eh muitas vezes especialmente durante a
transformação digital onde a importância
da tecnologia do time de tecnologia eh
se tornou tão importante né muito mais
importante do que era antes porque eu
lembro quando tecnologia não era o ré da
das coisas
hoje em dia Especialmente na empresa de
tecnologia quando fala vamos se tornar
uma empresa de tecnologia
Ahã e tecnologia se tornou de
verdade a parte talvez mais mais mais
importante claramente relativamente
falando né Eh de uma empresa e às vezes
isso cria o quê uma uma
distância né Eh se eu sou a organização
se eu sou a parte mais importante se o
meu trabalho se se o time de produto é o
mais importante
Ah você começa a se comportar como se
você é o mais importante se esquece que
é o mais importante é o cliente então
acho que talvez essa é uma poderia ser
uma uma das razões
H Mas eu também sinto que o excesso de
processo gera isso também o excesso de
processo no sentido que quando voltando
o que estava falando quando o processo
se torna o f em vez do como
eh eh Desculpa se torna é se torna fim
aem vez do cômodo que é aí você perde
essa conexão você você
eh continua esse afastamento do que é o
o o valor final o Por que você tá
fazendo aqui um e e como que você faz
para aproximar O time e aqui eu vou
falar tecnologia time de produto de
Engenharia e de design ao negócio e
também ao usuário porque o que que eu
reparo muitas vezes é vou usar aqui dois
exemplos tem Engenheiro que fala não eu
não quero saber do usuário não quero
saber do negócio me fala o que eu tenho
que fazer e eu vou fazer meu código aqui
e é isso tem design que é a mesma coisa
não quero saber me fala que eu tenho que
fazer vou fazer a tela e é isso como que
no dia a dia você tenta aproximar essas
pessoas seja da dor do usuário seja da
necessidade do negócio Como como que
você tenta quebrar esse silo no final
das contas é interessante
porque engraçado mesmo quando você pode
ser usuário do produto que você ent
porque muitas vezes você é muitas vezes
maioria talvez até as maioria maioria
das vezes você entrega um produto que
você trabalha numa empresa né que
portanto você se identifica com a missão
da empresa você nunca vai ser vai ser o
usuário desse produto né Depende do
claramente quanto mais você tem o
potencial e quanto mais você é usuário
do
produto quanto mais você consegue
estabelecer essa essa conexão Mas mesmo
mas mesmo assim é é cultural eh faz
parte de uma construção cultural que
tanto nos processos nas perguntas que
vocês faz que você faz nas nas
e nas decisões de prioridade sempre
provocando mas prioridade prioridade
para quem
ah eh para quem a gente está fazendo
isso qual é o produto é se conectar
culturalmente mente né E se torna uma
parte cultural quase como algo que a
gente precisa ensinar e e ensinar por
repetição ensinar por a eh cultura
cultura no final das contas é repetição
né e repetição e
eh comunidade do que que você
compartilha é isso que acho que a gente
precisa desenvolver se não existe uma
vez que você desenvolve e e e nutre aí
acho que você consegue fazer isso mas é
processo bem eh é um processo contínuo e
é um processo que precisa de muitas
pessoas que que apoiam e e que acredit
nisso eh não pode ser só uma pessoa que
que que que levanta esse esse tipo de
perguntas que levanta esse tipo de coisa
se conectar ao produto é ter exercícios
de conexão ao produto usuar em inglês né
a expressão e Dog food Isso faz parte
exatamente do que do que a gente está
falando que é se conectar a quem é o o o
cliente o usuário cliente final do que
você está fazendo do que você Fazendo do
que você está entregando falando sobre
empoderamento que a gente trabalhou
junto né a gente viveu essa jornada de
empoderar o chimes trazer
cultura O que que você achou que
foi em algum momento você sentiu o cara
agora agora o time tá empoderado agora
tá fazendo sentido ou a gente nunca
conseguiu atingir isso também pode ter
acontecido só você é só uma ilusão de
vozes na minha cabeça não aconteceu
aconteceu mesmo eu acho que
e a gente uma das coisas que até estavam
falando de como você só percebe de
quanto você alcançou depois porque
quando você tá no meio você perde um
pouco da prospectiva do quanto você
alcançou de quanto gente
eh amadureceu de como a gente se tornou
na verdade
um um líder no que a gente estava
fazendo né interessante você consegue
você consegue ter uma visão final quando
você se afasta quando você está no meio
das coisas você não não tem a
perspectiva total do que está
acontecendo e do que seja seja problem
também né ruim
ah mas sim eu acho que agora Agora
consigo entender até mais mas eu lembro
por exemplo hã como o nosso time de
produto né
conseguiu liderar dentro da empresa est
começar a liderar dentro da empresa
estratégia alinhamento e e ver isso
acontecendo com tanto com eh eh com
artefatos quanto com eh processos
e é ver que a impresa é o resto da
empresa olhava Olhava O produto para
respostas Olhava O produto para
eh começava a depender do produto muitas
vezes tem tem empresa onde às vezes eh
produto não é ou é distante ou ou não
entrega o que eh não tá alinhado
totalmente que começa a fazer coisas sem
até sem produto deix produto fazer
porque a gente não pode depender eu vi e
acho que um dos sinais foi verdade o
fato que começou a depender mais do
produto começou a contar mais eh com
produto
eh no no dia a dia nas decisões
estratégicas a gente tinha
muita especialmente com produto que a
Fernanda conseguiu fazer
H muita muita métricas muita organização
eh eh e menos achismos e mais eh fatos
eh resultados baseados em eh e
comprovados com com métricas métricas é
a coisa mais importante eh conseguir eh
eh medir o progresso eh os resultados e
tudo é acho que é a coisa mais
importante tanto em produto quanto em
tecnologia quanto em em qualquer outras
áreas e é uma das coisas que a gente
fala muito de métricas métricas mes mas
no final das contas eh
eh métricas Não ainda não fazem parte
totalmente da eh né do dos nossos
processos da nossa Cultura a gente está
ainda mais ao redor de processo em vez
de resultado e métrica são resultados eh
eu gosto muito de dizer números não tem
coração números não tem sentimentos
eh Essa é uma das coisas que eh eu achei
que a gente tinha uma uma muito boa eh
eh dominava muito bem e e você como
produto conseguiu muito dominar muito
bem
a a as métricas do do produto e que e
isso é super importante E aí nessa brisa
do número não tem sentimento uma das
coisas que eu fiquei refletindo e quero
dividir com você para ouvir um pouco Sua
percepção é no final das contas quando a
gente entrega experiência a gente
entrega um
sentimento exatamente Então como que a
gente faz para metrificar esses
sentimentos porque quando a gente olha
resultado de negócio a gente olha o
impacto no final né Toda empresa existe
para gerar caixa pra gente investir esse
caixa para distribuir pros
stakeholders só que como que você mede
esse sentimento porque uma das coisas
que a gente brinca muito assim o legal
do Zé gente que tatuou o Zé a gente faz
aniversário do Zé ISS você despertou um
sentimento e uma conexão tão grande que
a pessoa cara ela ama o Seu produto só
que como que a gente mede isso além do
NPS porque o NPS essa ele é uma métrica
que você vai medir depois como você vai
medindo isso ao longo do tempo eh essa é
uma ótima pergunta mas se me permitir eu
vou Ah aproveitar eh do que você falou
porque acho que é super importante para
mim quando pergunta as pessoas até
candidatas O que é experiência como é
que você define experiência muitas
poucas pessoas sabem te responder é um
porque quasi paresse ovvio não é paravra
ovvia esperienza um preciso definir mas
dentro de produto dentro de do nosso
contexto Na minha opinião experiência
tem uma definição bem eh importante e
você Fernanda usou uma coisa super
importante experiência O que é na minha
opinião experiência é produto claramente
você porque tem que ter um produto para
gerar uma experiência Mas além do
produto experiência é qual é o
sentimento que usar esse produto gera
essa é uma coisa super importante isso é
experiência o segundo at mais eh o
segundo até você mencionou também o
segundo ponto que você mencionou conexão
eh experiência é produto mas que é a
função então experiência é função mas
sentimentos ou eu eu uso mais a palavra
emoções Quais são as emoções que esse
que que essa função que você quer Eh
gerar E você tem que conter quando eu
falei lembra que está entregando uma
experiência se você não sabe que está
entregando uma experiência eh a
experiência Ainda você está entregando é
que não tem controle de qual experiência
você entregando então melhor saber que
você mesmo entregando o seu produto você
entrega uma experiência experiência
então é a função experiência é função
mais emoções mais conexões A Fernanda
falou muito sobre falou isso né Que tipo
de conexões com outras pessoas não
existe experiências solitárias são muito
São relativamente poucas a maior gente S
somos ser conectados né Eh Eu trabalho
numa empresa de eventos eh eventos é
forma melhor de de conexão até gosto de
dizer que eu falo que eventos s o
sistema linfático de uma sociedade
porque s com
essa é o sistema linfático que passa
todos os nutrientes ideias a as então
conexões e a terceira parte é o
que você desperta com essa função ou
quer despertar com essa função Então são
essas três coisas agora a pergunta é
como é que você mede como você mede
essas coisas e claramente tem formas
diferentes para medir
isso uma forma para medir na verdade é
você a forma mais simples é você
perguntar qual é
aação mas mesmo sem perguntar você pode
pode fazer
Ah pode entender de alguns eh alguns
comportamentos né Qual é a experiência
Qual é a experiência gerada sentida né
pelo pelo usuário e você consegue ser
ser é digital porque não tudo é digital
ainda mesmo mesmo no produto Então tem
que ter ah essa parte um pouco essa
parte sensorial e de detectar Quais s as
reações né da do do usuário com essa
experiência
então pode perguntar pode assistir pode
ver pode também olhar o
comportamento interessante o teste AB
não é só do e pode ser usado não só por
função mas pode ser usado também para
testar emoções Ah e a coisa importante é
que eh para mim super importante é que
você tem que saber qual emoção você quer
criar a gente usa também a a definição
de engenharia social não sei se se né É
É parte disso talvez eu eu quero
despertar essa emoção por exemplo em
produto eh especialmente Marketplace
escassez é uma das emoções que você sabe
que se você gera você consegue aumentar
conversão baseada nessa emoção
Ah então saber como como despertar as
emoções que que apoiam né O que você
qual é o seu objetivo final eh acho que
é super importante faz parte da do do
desenho do produto então testar como
testar de novo eh tem formas diferentes
não tem uma resposta única mas e
eh observar o comportamento seja tanto o
comportamento digital quanto o
comportamento uma das coisas
interessante que é super importante para
produto é é que às vezes a gente não não
presta tanta atenção dentro de produto
dentro da organização é marketing Ch de
marketing sempre presta atenção são esse
tipo de redes sociais você sa eh via
redes sociais Vocês conseguem entender
Qual
é aprender desculpa qual é a emoção que
que o uso do seu produto gera no cliente
porque eles te falam nem sem perguntar
Ah eu não precisa chegar até o reclame
aqui
e é algo que você consegue eh acompanhar
então muitas vezes eu eu eu h
eu faço Falo para meu time de produto
cara acompanha essa acompanha nossas
redes sociais acompanha isso porque a
gente vai ouvir as pessoas vai te falar
ah se é bom se é ruim como que eles se
sente então é super importante por isso
que acho que
experiência é produto é mais do que
experiência tem tem um um eu aprendi
isso H alguns anos atrás na hora que a
gente vai fazer Discovery
eh no Brasil principalmente acho que no
mundo todo mas no Brasil principalmente
a a gente mostra às vezes uma tela muito
bonita e as pessoas às vezes têm uma
reação Ah legal entendi bacana é uma
reação normal assim flat e quando você
mostra um protótipo que às vezes a
pessoa tem uma reação Nossa é isso que
eu preciso cara é qualitativo você não
faz isso em escala mas claramente você
tá vendo um sentimento de caramba é isso
que eu quero é isso que eu preciso é um
sinal muito forte de que você acertou no
seu protótipo ali e aí há quem diga que
se você você faz o o o Rabisco protótipo
feio e não muito bonito o a reação é
mais real porque as pessoas tem a
tendência de se tiver bonito ela diz tá
bacana às vezes tá horrível Ah tá bacana
que ela não quer falar mal do seu
trabalho mas se tem rabisco ela pode
dizer não tá muito ruim eu não entendi
nada e aí então às vezes até V fazer um
protótipo de menor qualidade para
conseguir colher o sentimento real ajuda
nesse processo prend uns anos atrás e
cara sempre me ajudou muito no no
Discovery você pega se entrevista das
pessoas às 10 ou 9 das 10 tiverem uma
reação ou muito positiva ou muito
negativa você já tem um sinal Se todas
foram neutro também tá errado porque
você Ah não sei deve ter um produto que
é bom ser neutro Mas no geral você não
quer ser neutro né no geral mas é muito
é muito engraçado o que você tá falando
interessante o que você está falando
porque
h o que você falou na verdade é o é o
Waterfall do ajal ou é o Waterfall da
metodologia as pessoas acham Ah vou
fazer pesquisa dois meses de pesquisa
porque senão não não dá para criar um
produto Porque sem pesquisa você não
pode criar um produto sainho você três
dias então mas não é só
independentemente se é claramente quanto
mais rápido melhor mas o ponto não é eu
sou rápido o ponto é que tem que ser
contínuo né
Eh e porque
eh a importância da des Discovery
contínua e é Aí sim que claramente
quanto mais Eh você não pode de fazer
Discovery contínuo você te demora do
meses para fazer Discovery então é é é
uma condição o fato que seja rápido é
uma é uma condição necessária mas não é
suficiente porque você pode fazer algo
rápido e depois nunca voltar
ah então o importante é ser Discovery
contínuo desenvolvimento contínuo
Ah porque às vezes eu sinto que a gente
tem ou eu chamo o Waterfall do do ajal
cascá cascajo cascá e cara é exatamente
isso é aprender então ver time de
produtos que são que fazem
desenvolvimento contínuo uhum
ah gosta também de dizer gost a gente
tem que se fazer todas as
perguntas fazer todas as perguntas
porque é importante saber quais são
saber as perguntas não precisamos ter
todas as respostas precisamos saber
responder o mínimo número o mínimo
número de respostas para você você
começar a fazer algo para você começar a
entregar algo porque a resposta final
sempre vem do cliente sempre vendo
usuário nunca vai vir da gente nunca vai
da gente então conceito de discovery
continuo conceito de desinvolvimento
iso se
applica architettura inia
tamb posso criar una mapa arquitetura
posso definir to e demorar Monte tempo
porque tenho que responder ah como é que
eu vou fazer isso como é que eu vou
fazer isso demorar um monte de tempo
depois quando você entrega a arquitetura
algo não funciona ou você não tinha
antecipado então o quanto antes você eh
se você me perguntar o que é a ja e eu
sempre eu falo que a a diferença entre a
Ja é qual é Waterfall
eh que antes da transformação digital a
gente respondia a pergunta quanto
mais quanto mais preciso saber quanto
mais resposta preciso ter quanto mais
coisas consigo colocar dentro do produto
quanto mais funcionalidade quanto mais
esse era o nosso mindset né tinha essa
quando na verdade na minha opinião
depois da transformação digital com
transformação digital com naal E aí por
isso que acho que às vezes ainda a gente
não está praticando o espírito do a na
letra é que responde quanto
menos quanto menos respostas preciso ter
para poder começar a fazer algo Quanto
quanto menos funcionalidade eu preciso
ter para entregar o meu primeiro produto
quanto menos tempo consigo fazer as
coisas é e é para mim essa essa é a
diferença principal a gente tá
acostumando ainda a responder quanto
mais eh ainda eu sinto organizações
empresas eu não estão acostumado a
responder quanto menos mas aí entra o
trick né da
liderança Como você consegue de alguma
forma segurar a
pressão para que porque as expectativas
às vezes é que se você já tem todas as
respostas e que você vai entregar aquilo
que Putz vai mudar o jogo eu tenho muito
né Eu brinco muito que as pessoas acham
que é Bala de Prata beleza Isso aqui vai
mudar o jogo não é não é É sempre um
conjunto de coisas mas como que você
como líder consegue tirar essa pressão
ou distribuir a direção como é que você
gerencia
isso tempo é é muito interessante is é
uma pergunta muito interessante porque
não é só eh de Fora pressão de Fora para
para organização de produto mas é também
por dentro né porque essa mesma essa
mesma pressão eh pressão até ansiedade
as pessoas não claramente a gente não
parte da ansiedade é de não saber o que
vai acontecer parte da ansiedade é não
saber não ter não ter as respostas né se
pa faz parte da da psicologia humana né
Ah então não é que a gente está falando
que pessoas boas ou pessoas ruins é a
nossa é a natureza né E e essa é uma
capacidade
eh
desenvolvida tem que
desenvolver então você pode tem que
desenvolver né Inteligência Emocional
você tem que olver e ajudar como líder a
desenvolver o o fato de sentir de estar
confortável com essa com essa abordagem
de estar confortável que e acreditar que
de verdade a gente não tem todas as
respostas a gente no final das contas
não sabe não importa quanto não importa
quanto você aprende não importa quanto
você mapeia não importa quanto Você
prevê claramente não pode fazer o oposto
né não pode ah vou jogar algo qualquer
coisa vou jogar isso não a gente não
está falando disso mas
eh tem também voltando a a Amazon eh
acho que je beos fal se
você se você precisa ter mais do que 70
60 70% das respostas você seja devagar
demais Além do fato que você não eh que
de novo você não sabe até o produto tá
na rua você não sabe até tá eh eh tá
sendo tá nas mãos dos nossos clientes
Então se acreditar no nesse processo
acreditar nesse processo e se acostumar
a desenvolver
eh
essa como dizer se acostumar ao fato que
não é necessário ter todas as respostas
sucesso também agora parte da ansiedade
é justificada por quê Porque esse
processo de contínuo Discovery
contínua desenvolvimento cont contínuos
delivery não é muito contínuo né porque
tem o foco muda não a gente não mantém a
disciplina e a gente esquece que e passa
para o próximo para o próximo desafio
então parte da dessa ansiedade ou dessa
pressão é justificada pelo fato que de
verdade não tem uma um um delivery e um
Discovery e uma entrega contínua aí sim
então parte é
mostrar mostrar que isso vai acontecer e
criar a confiança gerar a confiança
especialmente por time de pelo time de
produtos mostrar e gerar a confiança que
sim tô fazendo e quanto menos agora mas
depois o próximo vou te dar isso depois
o próximo vai acontecer isso depois o
próximo e aí gera confiança que você não
está só
ah tentando vender o pouco muito bom
muito bom Roberto muito obrigado pelo
papo Foi incrível deu para deu para
tirar vários insides e e acho que quem
tá ouvindo também ou assistindo se
questionar sobre processos e coisas que
tá fazendo e será que eu devia fazer
isso mesmo só porque um livro diz que é
desse jeito Será que não tem um jeito
mais eficiente e e você falou um pouco
também de Inteligência Emocional Acho
que tudo isso aqui que você falou além
de ter sido uma aula serve para todo
mundo e pra gente também né F refleti
então muito obrigado foi Foi incrível P
nosso papo obrigado a vocês bom Eu
normalmente falo isso no começo mas dado
que esqueci de falar isso falo eu eu não
tenho verdades eu só tenho opiniões
claro então eh acho que a diferença
entre verdade e opiniões é que você pode
mudar de de opinião é verdade é difícil
mudar então ess são as minha opiniões o
que eu aprendi no longo ao longo do
caminho Algumas crianças Sim mas são
opiniões e a gente aprende um das outras
é parte do aprendizado é também ser
disposto a mudar de opiniões perfeito
mais um aprendizado incrível é isso aí
exato Espero que você tenha gostado
desse Episódio e se você e para você que
ficou aqui até o final quero lembrar que
a gente tem a pm3 sprints onde a gente
ensina habilidades humanas soft Skills
para líderes ou para colaboradores
individuais que querem evoluir na
carreira ter autoconhecimento tem
inclusive uma experiente de Inteligência
Emocional tem algumas técnicas ali para
você se desenvolver nisso a gente tem um
cuponzinho de desconto para você que tá
acompanhando esse episódio a gente vai
deixar aqui na descrição e se você
gostou compartilha nos like da empresa
nos teams da empresa ou a ferramenta que
você usar tenho certeza que outras
pessoas podem se beneficiar Muito
obrigado e até a próxima